DESTRUCTION OF THE ORGANIZATION.
>> Sean: I KNOW I LOOK A LOT
YOUNGER THERE, BUT THE POINT IS
THAT THEY NEED TO CONFIRM HER AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESENT, FOX NEWS NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST.
NRA TV CONTRIBUTOR DAN BONGINO.
WE HAVE GOT TO START.
THE PRESIDENT KEEPS MAKING
PROMISES AND KEEPING THEM.
THE IDEA THAT YOU WILL SUCK UP
AND BRIBE DICTATORS, AND IF ONLY
WE ARE A LITTLE BIT NICER TO
THEM AND GIVE THEM $150 BILLION,
THEN THEY WILL BE NICE TO US.
WELL, PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU
IT BLEW THAT OUT OF THE WATER
LAST WEEK, AND STILL, PEOPLE
WANT TO STAY IN THIS BAD DEAL.
WHY?
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T LISTEN TO
THE PAST.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND HISTORY.
I SPENT LAST SUNDAY IN NEW YORK
WITH SOME HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS.
LET ME QUOTE A HOLOCAUST
SURVIVOR ON HIS LESSONS LEARNED
FROM WORLD WAR II.
HE HAD A VERY SIMPLE MESSAGE.
WHEN A GROUP OF PEOPLE
REPEATEDLY CALL FOR YOUR
DESTRUCTION, SOONER OR LATER, TO
TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY.
WELL, GUESS WHAT IRAN HAS BEEN
DOING SINCE 1979?
YOU DON'T GIVE THEM PALLETS OF
CASH.
YOU DON'T SIGN A DEAL THAT
REALLY DOESN'T STOP THEM
ACQUIRING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
YOU STOP THEM FROM GETTING THE
WEAPONS THEY WISH TO USE AGAINST
US AND OUR FRIENDS LIKE ISRAEL.
THE PRESIDENT KNEW THIS IN HIS
BONES.
THAT THE DEAL WOULD HAVE TO BE
KILLED.
HE JUST PUT IT TO 9-MILLIMETER
BULLETS AND ITS HEAD.
SHE ONCE YOU KNOW, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE DON'T LEARN
THE LESSONS OF HISTORY.
THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN NEGOTIATE
OR BRIBE DICTATORS, BRIBE THOSE
THAT CERTAIN TO DESTROY AMERICA,
DEATH TO AMERICA, DEATH TO
ISRAEL, AND SOMEHOW MONEY AND
BRIBERY WILL WORK.
THEY WORK IN NORTH KOREA, IT
DIDN'T WORK IN THIS DEAL, IT IS
NEVER GOING TO WORK.
AND I THINK THAT THE ONLY REASON
THAT KIM JONG-UN IS NOW WILLING
TO TALK IS BECAUSE THE SHOW OF
MILITARY FORCE, THE PRESIDENT
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA,
AND TO THE FACT THAT KIM JONG-UN
KNEW HE WAS GOING TO LOSE
EVERYTHING.
>> YES, SEAN, A COUPLE THINGS.
THE IRAN DEAL FIRST.
YOU KNOW, SOMEONE SHOULD HAVE
INFORMED THE IRANIANS THERE WAS
A DEAL.
THIS WAS NEVER A NEGOTIATION, IT
WAS A MANIPULATION.
THEY PLAY TO THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR FOOLS.
I WILL ASK YOU A SIMPLE
QUESTION.
LET'S GET SOME COMMON SENSE
HERE.
IT DOLLARS TO DOUGHNUTS.
THE IRANIANS PREVENTED US FROM
LOOKING AT MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS TO HAVE THOSE
INSTALLATIONS FOR THE PRODUCTION
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WHERE THE HECK DO YOU THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO PRODUCE A
NUCLEAR WEAPON?
THE LOCAL WALMART?
OF COURSE THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT
IN THE MILITARY INSTALLATION.
I MEAN, THIS IS COMMON SENSE.
THIS WAS NEVER A DEAL.
THE IRANIANS NEVER HAD ANY
INTENTION OF STICKING TO THIS
DEAL, AND I APPLAUD
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR THROWING TO
STEAL OUT THE WINDOW.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT GINA
HASPEL.
HER PERSONAL COMMITMENT, AND
UNDER MY LEADERSHIP OF THE CIA
WILL NOT RESTART THE DETENTION
AND INTERROGATION PROGRAM.
I AM ASSUMING THAT MEANS WE ARE
NOT GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER EVENT
LIKE 9/11, WHICH I THINK CREATED
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES.
SPEAK OUT NOBODY CAN MAKE THAT
STATEMENT.
I THINK SHE'S FOLLOWING THE
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IN
THE UNITED STATES SINCE THAT
TIME.
I HAVE A SPECIFIC VIEW ON THIS.
I WAS A TRAINED INTERROGATOR IN
THE U.K.
I'M NOT A MASSIVE FAN OF
ENHANCED INTERROGATION, BUT
SOMETIMES, WHEN THERE IS A
TICKING TIME BOMB, AND WHEN YOU
MAY BE SAVING THOUSANDS OF
LIVES, THEN THAT DECISION MIGHT
HAVE TO BE TAKEN.
AND REMEMBER, AS YOU HAVE TOLD
SO MANY TIMES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE
HUNG UP DURING THE
INTERROGATIONS IN AMERICA?
THREE.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS NOT SOME SORT OF LABOR
CAMP, WHERE WE ARE JUST USING
THIS.
THE WORST OF THE WORST WERE
COMPELLED TO GIVE UP INFORMATION
THAT SAVED LIVES.
AT THE END OF THIS.
>> Sean: AT LAST WORD.
>> YEAH, I AGREE.
I AM NOT A BIG FAN OF THAT
INTERROGATION.
BUDGET STANDING FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME, SLEEP
DEPRIVATION, THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
LONG DAY AND THE SECRET SERVICE,
WHERE I USED TO WORK.